(TV) "Ils sont frère et sœur,
ils sont jumeaux"
"et ils veulent se marier."
"La famille
ne comprend pas leur amour..."
(Voix off) "T'es trop un pote."
Framboisine? Qu'est-ce qui se passe?
- C'est fini avec Thierril.
je suis partie de chez lui
en prenant toutes mes affaires.
Ben entre, reste pas dehors
-Merci, c'est gentil.
Merci hein,
je voulais pas déranger.
Tu déranges pas du tout.
Promis, je resterai pas longtemps.
Je dormirai sur le clic clac.
Ah oui non mais le clic clac
c'est aussi mon lit en fait.
Ah.
Bon, laisse, c'est pas grave,
je vais aller à l'hôtel...
Non non non, reste,
c'est pas grave,
je dormirai sur une chaise.
T'es sûr?
-Oui oui.
Ok. C'est sympa.
Je me demandais, est-ce que t'aurais
du shampoing et du démêlant?
Ben non.
Ah ben oui, je suis bête.
C'est embêtant ça parce que moi
j'aime bien prendre une douche
avant d'aller me coucher.
Si tu veux y'a une boutique
qui ferme tard au coin de la rue.
C'est vrai?
T'irais en chercher pour moi?
Tu veux que j'y aille?
- Oui. Non. Pardon,
je croyais que tu me proposais
parce que t'avais vu
que j'ai mes valises à défaire.
Ben oui, de toute façon
je vais y aller parce que...
j'ai des trucs à acheter donc euh...
Eh ben merci, t'es trop chou.
Ah, est-ce que tu pourrais
prendre aussi des tampons?
Parce que si je reste plusieurs jours,
on sait jamais.
Monseigneur.
Jiluc Stark, vous m'entendez?
On ne devrait pas
se laisser expulser du château de cette manière.
Vous ne pouvez accepter cet exil.
Monseigneur,
arrêtez de regarder ce tableau.
Pardon.
Mais elle m'a tout pris.
Elle a même pris le clic clac.
Y'a moyen de reprendre tout ce qui est à nous,
et même plus!
Il est à vous ce clic clac.
C'est pas elle qui s'est tapé
l'aller-retour à Ikea en Kangoo.
Vous avez raison,
elle va payer ses dettes.
Ici, c'est chez moi.
Oui.
-Et j'irai pas t'acheter des tampons.
D'accord.
Mais là j'en n'ai pas besoin.
Et le clic clac, on le partage.
Merci hein, t'es trop un pote.
(Voix off) "T'es trop un pote."
Vous avez déjà
récupéré votre territoire Seigneur,
que voulez-vous de plus?
Il me reste votre cœur à conquérir.
Lover is coming!
Allez, continue!
Oh, oui, putain!